bail is set at 15 million dollars for
the gunman who held around 30 people
hostage at a Trader Joe's grocery store
in Los Angeles for three hours this past
July the shoppers feared for their lives
and now for the first time some of them
are sharing the chilling details about
what happened inside the store and how
they got out alive Jim Axelrod shares
this powerful story of survival and
courage on this week's 48 hours Saturday
July 21st was a really nice summer day
it was sunny just like every single day
has been since I moved here I'm gonna go
get groceries for us for the week
I love grocery shopping I was coming
right up on the Trader Joe's I thought
oh I'll just go in there on a summer day
in Los Angeles Lynn west of her Mary
Lynn demas Cory Paige and artists John
balázs were among dozens of shoppers who
crowded the aisles at this Trader Joe's
what they didn't know was just miles
away police were on a manhunt police
that started searching for that car
police say gene Atkins had shot his
grandmother and then kidnapped his
girlfriend he was now leading them on a
wild chase Atkins crashed his car in
front of the Trader Joe's and ran inside
exchanging gunfire with the LAPD
the store manager 27 year old male to
Corrado
was caught in the crossfire and
accidentally killed by a police bullet I
was terrified I didn't know what I
should do well I don't know I don't know
what's gonna happen like none of us know
what's gonna happen here 100% I thought
it was a mass shooting we're all going
to die Cory ran into a closet with a
glass window in the back of the store
and hid with 20 other people he took
these photos we are fully exposed we are
sitting ducks and then I saw the
assailant the gun is in his right hand
this situation still unfolding right now
here at the Trader Joe's outside the
LAPD SWAT team arrived and surrounded
the store the assailant looks out the
door and he says what is that sniper
doing on the roof and sure enough there
was a sniper on the roof of the cheese
store next door to the Trader Joe's the
gun aimed right at us
gene Atkins spoke on the phone with a
police negotiator he says if you don't
get him off the roof I'm gonna shoot
somebody I'm gonna shoot somebody in
five four three two Wow I'm Jim Axelrod
joins an enormous league ripping hour of
television it really is so how are they
able to escape you know we've all had
this experience I'm sure we're it's one
of the unfortunate parts of the time in
which we live we always think what if I
was in a movie theater what if I was
some well this is a what would I do now
so Mary Linda Moss who we just saw she
kind of wraps the situation in a blanket
of humanity and decides she's gonna get
out by establishing a human connection
with the gunman gene Atkins so she does
starts talking to him and then begins
working in tandem with the LAPD
negotiator to work out
terms that they can all walk out I don't
want to give the ending away but I'm
telling you when they walk out at the
end it is it is just a compelling and
powerful I believe I'm curious about the
gunman because what kind of guy do you
have to be to shoot your grandmother
yeah think about that for a second yeah
he's he's facing 50 counts of attempted
murder kidnapping and we'll give you the
rest of the story tomorrow yeah that was
a good tease Jim thank you nicely done
and you can watch Jim's report live to
towel standoff at Trader Joe's on 48
hours at that Saturday 10:00 9:00
central right here on CBS